Barack Obama strongly defended his
health-care legislation he spoke last
night when he received the Profile in
Courage Award at the John F Kennedy boom
Presidential Library mr. Obama called on
Congress to have the courage to do what
is right regardless of politics Jen
corporate is covering the former
president re-entry into the health care
debate dan good morning well good
morning Charlie you know President Obama
didn't mention president Trump by name
during that more than 30 minute speech
but he did take the opportunity to
defend the health care bill that he
considers to be his main legislative
legacy there was a reason why health
care reform had not been accomplished
before it was hard accepting an award
for courage President Obama shared
recognition with members of Congress who
lost their seats supporting Obama care
these men and women did the right thing
they did the hard thing theirs was a
Profile in Courage because of that vote
20 million people got health insurance
who didn't have it before President
Obama made no mention of his successor
this is a repeal and a replace of
Obamacare make no mistake about it who
three days earlier celebrated a narrow
vote in the House to undo mr. Obama's
signature achievement replace it with a
plan Republicans say will be more
effective long-term I hope that current
members of Congress recall that it
actually doesn't take a lot of courage
to aid those who are already powerful
but it does require some courage to
champion the vulnerable and the second
sticking to the theme of the night the
44th president urged lawmakers to choose
people over parties it is my fervent
hope that today's members of Congress
regardless of party are willing to look
at the facts and speak the truth even
when it contradicts party positions now
Democrats including President Obama
didn't fix issues with Obamacare in the
last few years of his presidency and now
they are banking on push back to the
Republican health care bill to help
them win back seats in Congress in 2018
as today President Obama heads to Italy
to give a keynote address on climate
change Nora
all right Jan thank you so much